hi there hi there steve here
and uh i'm nearing the end of my korean
challenge
uh essentially i'm just i'm mostly
reading and of course i'm listening but
i don't understand a lot of what i hear
and
so the major activity that i'm doing
that i'm enjoying is my listening excuse
me my reading and reading i want to
dwell a bit on on reading because it's
such a powerful thing to do and i talk
about reading and then i'm going to talk
about some of these
teaching fads like
different learning styles or teaching
critical thinking which i think are
quite unnecessary
and that reading is the fundamental
empowerment tool that anyone involved in
education should be
most concerned about so
first of all in so far as my korean
i'm reading my korean history book with
the hanja which i'm enjoying and i'm
learning a lot about korean history
which is is fun i mean you got to enjoy
the history the culture of the language
and of course i read on my ipad
and there i have the advantage that uh
you know i can hear
you know i go i can hear individual
words
or if i create a phrase i can listen to
the phrase
and if i listen to the phrase
so and it's kind of helpful that if i
had that
coupled with
my
history book with the hunji i'd be in
heaven but i don't have that i continue
reading about the events in korea right
now the impeachment of the president and
all the stuff that's happening there
but reading i i
keep on getting back to this reading is
so important i noticed for example well
let's get back to boston the actful
american council of teachers of foreign
languages conference
where the teachers were all talking
about compel
most people i spoke to were talking
about compelling input compelling
content things that krashen is talking
about
things that bill van patten is talking
about
and a lot of what they're into is
finding or or
working with people who are creating
um
accessible content in other words
stories that are at a level that the
learner can deal with
and of course what a person is
interested is going to vary i may not be
interested in those stories maybe i'm
keener to fight my way through this
difficult uh political podcast but i
think a majority of people would rather
read simple stories read read read and
so there's more and more of these
readers being developed especially for
spanish which after all in the united
states is the number one
second language that's taught in the
schools
and you'll remember that there was a
fellow that came on here and said crash
and has ruined language instruction and
then he told me that he had 200 private
messages at his blog like there were no
comments
uh on this blog that he put out but he
said there were 200 private
uh messages to him saying that they
agreed with him and that the crash is
terrible and stuff like that however
bill van patten has just been elected
president of the spanish teachers
association in the united states so
perhaps it's not true that a majority of
teachers are rebelling against krashen's
ideas or bill van patten's ideas which
are largely the same but rather more
like it they are continuing to try to
get these ideas introduced in the
classroom because you can get people to
read and read a lot they're going to do
well in their own language in their own
academic or professional careers and in
learning foreign languages and we know
that in most societies 30 40 percent of
the people have poor functional literacy
skills they don't read well they
struggle with uh text that are in any
way complicated and yet in the workplace
uh even to read a manual if you're gonna
work in a factory somewhere nowadays you
need a good command of english and so
and and i mentioned too that that the
statistics of
you know the the the social cost of of
poor reading skills is tremendous people
who are in prison and so forth and so on
are overwhelmingly people who don't
read well so reading is the fundamental
skill for language learning and for life
read and that's why i get so annoyed
when i see these language teachers
obsess over things like teaching
critical thinking or teaching higher
thinking skills or something like that
critical thinking i mean all you need
really to be able to have critical
thinking skills you have to have an open
mind
and you have to know a lot of stuff
because the more you know the more the
more you're able to evaluate
the content that you're reading if you
know nothing about the subject you don't
even understand perhaps what they're
talking about if you have read widely on
it and you know the history of this and
you know different theories the more you
have read the better you capable you are
of interpreting of analyzing or of even
challenging but of course the whole
critical thinking thing is all about
getting people to challenge everything
challenge our society their companies
are corrupt and ripping us off the
system is uh you know unfair all of this
challenging the established society
whereas i tend to feel that we the
society we live in is actually quite
good we're doing quite well in terms of
health standards in terms of longevity
in terms of
um you know standard of living compared
to 50 years ago not only in north
america but in most parts of the world
so this critical thinking is more of a
political agenda
uh
really
getting people
to
be able to read critically primarily
means getting them to read better
more words more vocabulary read faster
in order to read more so that they're in
a better position to evaluate what they
read
the same is true for this learning
styles thing that some people have
kinetic learning or visual learning
there everyone needs to learn to read
yes
depending on
what the child already knows depending
on what the child likes to do
or an adult then they may have
different preferences but i think
fundamentally the brain learns the same
way and fundamentally we know that high
literacy
is the best guarantee of both academic
and eventually professional success not
for everyone but statistically
overwhelmingly and if that's the case
if you are teaching in a school don't
worry
about all these learning styles which
has been debunked by the way it's you
just go google you know learning fads
learning styles is a fad for that matter
critical thinking is a fad you'll find
lots of serious
studies that debunk all of this
and instead the focus should be on
teaching people to read and if you're a
language learner focus on becoming a
good reader in the language that you're
learning now maybe all you need to do is
exchange a few pleasantries or you don't
want to go to the trouble of learning
chinese characters
fine but you're going to miss out
ultimately you won't you'll only be able
to go so far so
that's what i wanted to say today about
about the importance of reading
and because reading is so important and
should be the focus of any teaching
program therefore i think this
getting sidetracked into learning styles
and teaching critical thinking is only a
smokescreen a distraction from the
fundamental
task the teaching of the fundamental
skill
reading
there you have it i just thought i'd get
that off my chest today so bye for now